Shure:  土豆
Shure: Potato.
Katrina:  土豆侠吃土
Katrina: Potato man eating dirt.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: Here's another one.
Shure:  以塔塔ki马斯
Shure: Itadakimasu.
Alice: 他够不到
Alice: He can't reach it.
Alice: 我们挪一下啊
Alice: Let's move it a bit.
Alice: 那边还有一个
Alice: There's another one over there.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  我靠 6张披萨
Shure: Whoa, six pizzas.
Tasha: 天不是吧
Tasha: Oh my, really?
Lucia: 哎哎为什么会是6个披萨呢
Lucia: Hey, hey, why do we have six pizzas?
Jake: 买2赠2啊
Jake: Buy 2, get 2 free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: What?
Alice: 啊现在有那个活动
Alice: Oh, they have that promotion now.
Lucia: 但我们不是买了
Lucia: But we didn't buy...
Lucia: 就是我还以为是我们买4个
Lucia: I thought we bought 4 of them
Lucia: 其中有两个是送的呢
Lucia: And two were free
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice: 不行
Alice: No way
Alice: 我想在这
Alice: I want to stay here
Katrina:  从未打过这么富裕的仗
Katrina: I've never fought such a wealthy battle
Katrina:  这么多箱子
Katrina: So many boxes
Jake: 对流水席
Jake: Yeah, it's like a banquet
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Katrina:  哦对
Katrina: Oh right
Katrina:  可以站在这边站着吃吧
Katrina: Can we stand and eat here?
Jake: 站着吃吧
Jake: Let's stand and eat
Jake: 要不就
Jake: Otherwise...
Katrina:  行啊
Katrina: Sure
Shure:  要不我们什么击鼓传花停哪就
Shure: How about we play hot potato and wherever it stops, we eat there?
Shure:  哈哈哈就吃哪啊
Shure: Hahaha, and just eat there?
Jake: 那你把你的音箱拿上来
Jake: Then bring your speaker up here
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No
Jake: 手套可以
Jake: Gloves will do
Tasha: 嘿嘿机械
Tasha: Hey, mechanical stuff
Shure:  没开是吗
Shure: Is it not on?
Katrina:  我说开了
Katrina: I said it's on
Katrina:  我看有多少电量
Katrina: Let me check the battery
Katrina:  要不要充一会
Katrina: Should we charge it a bit?
Tasha: 嗯谢谢
Tasha: Yeah, thanks
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Katrina:  我亮了吗
Katrina: Am I lit?
Shure:  你亮着
Shure: You're lit
Katrina:  他怎么肯定
Katrina: How can he be sure?
Katrina:  还挺吓我一跳我们遛一下
Katrina: He really startled me, let's take a walk
Lucia: 三个多余的哈哈哈
Lucia: Three extras, hahaha
Alice: 可以开始了吗
Alice: Can we start now?
Lucia: 可以尝尝
Lucia: You can taste it
Jake: 我先吃也行
Jake: I can eat first, no problem
Jake: 问题不大问题不大问题不大
Jake: No problem, no problem, no problem
Jake: 一切都充满着变化
Jake: Everything is ever-changing
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Hahaha, no problem
Tasha: 早知道点两个榴莲了
Tasha: Should have ordered two durians
Jake: 子涵喝水
Jake: Zihan, drink some water
Jake: 你喝哪一个
Jake: Which one are you drinking?
Jake: 几号
Jake: What date is it?
Katrina:  今天是什么活动
Katrina: What's the event today?
Katrina:  这个怎么会有6个
Katrina: How come there are six of these?
Katrina:  买4赠2
Katrina: Buy 4, get 2 free.
Shure:  买一赠一
Shure: Buy one, get one free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Tasha: 我刚才想买4个的话是会不会不够
Tasha: I was just wondering if buying 4 would be enough.
Tasha: 他这是九寸的
Tasha: This one is nine inches.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, yeah.
Katrina:  连晚饭都解决了
Katrina: Even dinner is sorted.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 啊也好
Jake: Ah, that's good too.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  一会自己操作一下
Shure: Try to do it yourself later.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake: 嗯这边都是什么管家代取了
Jake: Hmm, here everything is managed by the concierge.
Jake: 就是请我
Jake: Just ask me.
Jake: 我让他们取一下吧
Jake: I'll have them get it.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 那我告诉你号码还是什么呀
Jake: So, should I give you the number or what?
Alice: 要榴莲的吗
Alice: Do you want durian?
Jake: 53愈合期
Jake: 53, healing period.
Jake: 53还是您
Jake: 53, still you.
Jake: 您要什么呀
Jake: What do you want?
Katrina:  喝了咖啡
Katrina: Had coffee.
Jake: 打电话吧
Jake: Make a call.
Katrina:  你的食欲会下降
Katrina: Your appetite will decrease.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 好就是我们其实3031栋
Jake: Okay, actually we are at building 3031.
Jake: 玉河区31栋
Jake: Yuhe District, building 31.
Jake: 玉河区31 啊
Jake: Yuhe District 31, ah.
Jake: 玉河区31
Jake: Yuhe District 31.
Jake: 佑佑的院子
Jake: Youyou's yard.
Jake: 啊可以可以对
Jake: Ah, okay, okay, right.
Jake: 嗯好嘞好嘞谢谢
Jake: Hmm, alright, alright, thanks.
Tasha: 饱了保护我自己了
Tasha: I'm full, I protected myself.
Katrina:  披萨好管饱的
Katrina: Pizza is really filling.
Shure:  感觉吃了一半就已经饱了
Shure: I felt full after eating just half.
Tasha: 吃了两片
Tasha: I had two slices.
Katrina:  带出去野餐吧
Katrina: Let's take it out for a picnic.
Tasha: 嗯带出去野餐吧
Tasha: Yeah, let's take it out for a picnic.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  走累了搞搞个那野餐
Katrina: When we're tired, we can have a picnic.
Katrina:  那一坐就开始吃
Katrina: Just sit down and start eating.
Katrina:  吃完又走
Katrina: Eat and then keep walking.
Jake: 吃不完带走
Jake: If we don't finish, we can take it with us.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 再去采风是吧
Tasha: Then we'll go sightseeing again, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 这个应该可以吃完
Jake: We should be able to finish this.
Tasha: 应该可以吃完
Tasha: We should be able to finish it.
Jake: 不是就是今天的时候
Jake: Not like before when we had to throw it away.
Jake: 嗯不会像之前一样丢掉
Jake: Yeah, we won't waste it like last time.
Jake: 丢到第二天就没有用了
Jake: Last time, we threw it away and it was useless the next day.
Shure:  煤气高钙
Shure: Gas and high calcium.
Shure:  不能浪费食物
Shure: We shouldn't waste food.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 瘦了吧唧
Alice: So skinny.
Shure:  看我昨天还看的那个梗
Shure: Look, I saw this joke yesterday.
Shure:  然后就是绑着他强制喂他吃榴莲披萨
Shure: And then tying him up and forcing him to eat durian pizza.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为是
Lucia: I thought it was...
Lucia: 夏威夷披萨呢
Lucia: Hawaiian pizza.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Almost the same.
Tasha: 榴莲披萨
Tasha: Durian pizza.
Tasha: 这么好吃
Tasha: It's so delicious.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 就是意大利人看到给披萨上放水果
Lucia: Italians would freak out seeing fruit on pizza.
Lucia: 会非常的崩溃
Lucia: They'd lose it.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  咱们饺子里面放水果给你吃一样
Shure: It's like putting fruit in dumplings for you to eat.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 他们传统披萨上面是不放水果的
Lucia: Traditionally, they don't put fruit on pizza.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Shure:  肉夹馍突然给你加了一个番茄酱
Shure: Imagine putting ketchup on a roujiamo
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 没关系我觉得番茄酱蘸什么都好吃
Tasha: It's okay, I think ketchup makes everything taste good.
Lucia: 肉夹馍为什么要放番茄酱
Lucia: Why would you put ketchup on a roujiamo?
Tasha: 丰富口感吧
Tasha: To add some flavor, I guess.
Lucia: 异端
Lucia: That's blasphemy.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: How about putting cheese on saozi noodles?
Lucia: 臊子面放cheese
Lucia: Cheese on saozi noodles?
Lucia: 但这我怎么觉得还好
Lucia: Actually, I think that's okay.
Lucia: 还可以接受
Lucia: I can accept that.
Tasha: 我也可以接受
Tasha: I can accept that too.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Cheese on saozi noodles.
Lucia: 还有美国的那种做成甜了的披萨
Lucia: And those sweet pizzas from America.
Lucia: 好像意大利人也会觉得很崩溃
Lucia: Italians must be horrified by them.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 今天还有布朗尼披萨吗
Tasha: Do we still have brownie pizza today?
Lucia: 你猜吧哦买噶
Lucia: Take a guess. Oh my god.
Jake: 今晚做一个
Jake: Let's make one tonight.
Tasha: 啊我说达美乐的时候啊
Tasha: I was talking about Domino's.
Jake: 真他有啊
Jake: They really have it?
Tasha: 他有啊
Tasha: They do.
Lucia: 他有
Lucia: They have it.
Jake: 他真的有
Jake: They really have it.
Lucia: 达美乐有这个味
Lucia: Domino's has that flavor.
Tasha: 布朗尼的
Tasha: Brownie flavor.
Tasha: 还有各种各样甜的披萨
Tasha: And all sorts of sweet pizzas.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Do you eat durian?
Shure:  你好像触发了什么
Shure: Seems like you triggered something.
Shure:  NPC对话
Shure: NPC dialogue.
Shure:  吃吃吃
Shure: Eat, eat, eat.
Shure:  稍等稍等
Shure: Hold on, hold on.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha: 他是那天唯一一个点那个榴莲汉堡的
Tasha: He was the only one who ordered that durian burger that day.
Tasha: 跟我一起
Tasha: Along with me.
Jake: 一些珍贵的人类吃披萨镜头
Jake: Some rare footage of humans eating pizza.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: My
Lucia: 眼镜怎么这两天又开始疯狂的往下滑
Lucia: glasses keep slipping down these past two days.
Jake: 这两天瘦了
Jake: I've lost weight these past couple of days.
Shure:  真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 不能吧
Lucia: No way.
Shure:  这都吃瘦了
Shure: You lost weight even after eating?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 吃瘦了
Jake: Lost weight from eating.
Jake: 太辛苦了
Jake: It’s been too exhausting.
Jake: 剧组太辛苦了
Jake: The crew's work is too exhausting.
Shure:  天哪
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  我们这剧组
Shure: Our crew...
Jake: 把人这两天把人吃瘦了
Jake: They've made people lose weight in just two days.
Lucia: 哈哈不至于吧
Lucia: Haha, that's not possible.
Shure:  供吃供住
Shure: They provide food and lodging.
Tasha: 能不瘦吗哈哈哈
Tasha: How could you not lose weight? Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Jake: 这个有问题
Jake: There's something wrong here.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Jake: 我记一下
Jake: Let me note this.
Tasha: 大家只能挤着一起吃披萨
Tasha: Everyone can only squeeze together to eat pizza.
Tasha: 而不是一个人娱乐
Tasha: Instead of enjoying it alone.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Exactly.
Tasha: 就已经已经遭受不公平的待遇了
Tasha: They've already suffered unfair treatment.
Jake: 不是就
Jake: It's not just...
Shure:  这段数据要删掉
Shure: This segment needs to be deleted.
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 小心小心你这个
Jake: Be careful with this.
Jake: 增加我们很多工作量啊
Jake: It increases our workload a lot.
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 我要记一下
Jake: Let me note this.
Lucia: 啊什么要删掉
Lucia: Ah, what needs to be deleted?
Lucia: 吃披萨吗
Lucia: Eating pizza?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Tasha: 12.09
Tasha: 12.09.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 受了不公平的待遇
Tasha: Suffered unfair treatment.
Shure:  你看你又说了一遍
Shure: Look, you said it again.
Shure:  他又在说
Shure: He’s saying it again.
Shure:  逼逼一句
Shure: Just one more time.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 就这这逼逼逼逼逼的
Jake: Just this, this beep beep beep beep.
Jake: 你们继续吃你们的
Jake: You guys keep eating.
Jake: 但是边吃边逼逼逼
Jake: But eat while beeping.
Lucia: 那
Lucia: Well...
Lucia: 我们之前出现了多少要被道德词汇
Lucia: How many moral words did we use before?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: F word的是不是也要
Lucia: Should we also beep the F word?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina:  昨天还看到直升机了
Katrina: I saw a helicopter yesterday.
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Oh yeah.
Katrina:  军用的
Katrina: A military one.
Lucia: 对军用的是不是会侵占他的版权啊
Lucia: Right, would a military one infringe on his copyright?
Shure:  看一眼
Shure: Let's take a look.
Tasha: 我们昨天放的电影
Tasha: The movie we watched yesterday.
Tasha: 要不要删掉
Tasha: Should we delete it?
Lucia: 我忘了
Lucia: I forgot.
Shure:  咱们昨天吃火锅没戴眼镜
Shure: We ate hot pot without glasses yesterday.
Katrina:  哦空调遥控器呢
Katrina: Oh, where's the AC remote?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  不想看来着
Katrina: Didn't want to look.
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  薇薇
Katrina: Tasha.
Katrina:  昨天那个空调遥控器是不是在你那
Katrina: Was the AC remote with you yesterday?
Katrina:  薇薇嗯遥控器
Katrina: Tasha, yeah, the remote.
Tasha: 不在我那
Tasha: Not with me.
Tasha: 我说放在外面的桌上了
Tasha: I said I left it on the table outside.
Shure:  空调遥控器
Shure: The AC remote.
Katrina:  2楼不通风有点热
Katrina: The second floor isn't ventilated, it's a bit hot.
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: It's here.
Lucia: 这俩是同一个味吗
Lucia: Do these two taste the same?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 可能你加了之后
Tasha: Maybe after you added it,
Tasha: 我又不小心又加了一遍
Tasha: I accidentally added it again.
Lucia: 不不不
Lucia: No, no, no.
Lucia: 有哪位宝宝需要餐巾纸吗
Lucia: Does anyone need a napkin?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh
Lucia: 需要吗
Lucia: Do you need one?
Tasha: 等一下就需要
Tasha: I will in a bit
Lucia: 那我先放在你这里
Lucia: I'll leave it here for you then
Tasha: 哦我这怎么了
Tasha: Oh, what's up with me?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Shure:  哦不
Shure: Oh no
Alice: 下雪了
Alice: It's snowing
Tasha: 大家够用吗
Tasha: Is there enough for everyone?
Lucia: 要
Lucia: Yes
Jake: 谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you
Shure:  张万森下雪了
Shure: It's snowing, Zhang Wansen
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Katrina:  我再来一张吧
Katrina: Can I have another one?
Lucia: 如果谁需要纸可以传递一下
Lucia: If anyone needs a napkin, just pass it around
Shure:  是带那个
Shure: Is this with...
Shure:  洗洁精的湿巾是吗
Shure: Wet wipes with detergent?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah
Shure:  哈哈我擦擦
Shure: Haha, let me wipe
Alice: 对了
Alice: By the way
Shure:  怎么感觉味不对
Shure: Why does it smell weird?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈再舔起泡了
Katrina: Hahaha, it's foaming when you lick it
Lucia: 哎什么东西
Lucia: Hey, what's that?
Lucia: 带洗洁精
Lucia: With detergent?
Alice: 那个厨房湿巾
Alice: Those kitchen wipes
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice: 咂嘴
Alice: Smack
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice: 一个宝贵的数据
Alice: A precious piece of data
Shure:  哎我记得我刚才掉了一块肉在这
Shure: Oh, I remember I dropped a piece of meat here
Shure:  怎么找不到了
Shure: Why can't I find it?
Jake: 掉什么了
Jake: What did you drop?
Jake: 掉披萨了啊
Jake: Did you drop pizza?
Shure:  啊不是那个有一块
Shure: No, it was a piece of meat
Shure:  刚才掉了一块肉
Shure: I remember dropping a piece of meat
Shure:  我记得掉地下了
Shure: I remember it fell on the floor
Shure:  掉下找不到了
Shure: And now I can't find it
Shure:  行了留给蟑螂先生了
Shure: Alright, leave it to Mr. Cockroach.
Lucia: 为什么你们
Lucia: Why do you all...
Tasha: 每个盘都送的好均匀啊
Tasha: Each dish is so evenly distributed.
Shure:  一两个两个两个
Shure: One, two, two, two.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Katrina:  他俩不是一个
Katrina: Aren't they a pair?
Alice: 所以这个是
Alice: So this is...
Katrina:  我要问一下他是讲新课还是讲复习课
Katrina: I need to ask if he's teaching a new class or a review class.
Katrina:  这个得等他回来才知道
Katrina: We'll have to wait until he comes back to know.
Tasha: 要不要把整盒整盒
Tasha: Should we combine the whole boxes?
Jake: 好啊拼一拼
Jake: Sure, let's mix them up.
Tasha: 这俩可以直接拼过来了
Tasha: These two can be combined directly.
Tasha: 把这个拼在一起
Tasha: Let's put these together.
Tasha: 对这好像就差两块
Tasha: Right, it seems we're just two pieces short.
Jake: 这就是什么什么
Jake: This is like...
Jake: 油泼面拌臊子面
Jake: Oil-splashed noodles mixed with braised noodles.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 必胜客经典二合一
Lucia: Pizza Hut's classic combo.
Jake: 这二合一确实很好
Jake: This combo is really good.
Lucia: 不行我现在站不起来了哈哈
Lucia: I can't even stand up now, haha.
Shure:  这个改过的
Shure: This has been modified.
Shure:  结构大概是这个样子
Shure: The structure is roughly like this.
Shure:  想带上我的一切
Shure: I want to take everything with me.
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then...
Shure:  这是水是吧
Shure: This is water, right?
Shure:  20
Shure: 20.
Shure:  不能
Shure: Can't.
Alice: 还有纸吗
Alice: Is there any paper left?
Shure:  逼着我喝水
Shure: Forcing me to drink water.
Jake: duo lin go是不是你很久没上
Jake: Duolingo, if you haven't used it for a long time...
Jake: 他就会把图标变得很丑
Jake: It will make the icon look ugly.
Lucia: 呃对
Lucia: Uh, right.
Jake: 就是就真的会很就变
Jake: It really changes, like, does it change for you?
Jake: 会变吗你变了吗
Jake: Did it change for you?
Lucia: 会变
Lucia: It does change.
Lucia: 就是如果说你好好久不去上课的话
Lucia: If you don't attend lessons for a long time...
Lucia: 他就会变成要么在睡觉的表情
Lucia: It changes to a sleeping face or...
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 要么就变成沙漠里的一个鸟骷髅
Lucia: Or it becomes a bird skeleton in the desert.
Jake: OK
Lucia: 然后如果你每天打卡的话
Lucia: And if you check in every day
Lucia: 他就会非常开心
Lucia: He will be very happy
Lucia: 那个表情
Lucia: That expression
Lucia: 如果你某一天当天没有打卡
Lucia: If you don't check in on a certain day
Lucia: 他就会就是呈现一个怒火的表情哦
Lucia: He will show an angry expression, oh
Lucia: 真的很有意思
Lucia: It's really interesting
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes
Shure:  这是真没有
Shure: This is really not
Lucia: 我觉得我最大的乐趣不来自于学语言
Lucia: I think my biggest fun doesn't come from learning the language
Lucia: 来自于观赏他
Lucia: It comes from watching him
Lucia: 这个图标射程
Lucia: The range of this icon
Jake: 可以
Jake: Alright
Jake: 嗯管家什么时候
Jake: Hmm, when will the butler
Jake: 我也不知道管家什么时候
Jake: I don't know when the butler will
Jake: 问话要
Jake: Ask questions
Shure:  nice
Shure: Nice
Shure:  我去搜个吉他谱
Shure: I'm going to look for a guitar tab
Shure:  应该是有的
Shure: There should be one
Shure:  伴奏我一会发你
Shure: I'll send you the accompaniment later
Shure:  我们现在是要交换礼物
Shure: Are we exchanging gifts now?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure:  好的走
Shure: Alright, let's go
Shure:  回答的
Shure: Answered
Shure:  这个是运动会
Shure: This is the sports event
Jake: 大伙看看自己眼镜还有多少电
Jake: Everyone check how much battery your glasses have left
Jake: 要不要插充电宝
Jake: Do you need to plug in a power bank?
Jake: 时间差不多了
Jake: It's about time
Shure:  一直在挂着尿袋
Shure: Always hanging with a urine bag
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright
Shure:  我们吃了4个披萨
Shure: We ate 4 pizzas
Shure:  相当于是吧
Shure: That's quite a lot, right?
Shure:  对吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure:  7个人4个披萨
Shure: 7 people, 4 pizzas
Lucia: 4624
Lucia: 28 大概每个人吃了三四块的样子
Lucia: 28, so each person ate about three or four pieces
Lucia: 为什么要算
Lucia: Why calculate?
Lucia: 条件反射的算一下
Lucia: Reflexively calculated
Lucia: 估算一下大家的饭量以后好点
Lucia: Estimating everyone's meal size for future reference
Shure:  之前还看过一个披萨笑话是
Shure: I once heard a pizza joke
Shure:  说披萨是最诚实的食物
Shure: It said pizza is the most honest food
Shure:  因为他没有欺骗
Shure: Because it doesn't deceive
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay
Lucia: 对不会
Lucia: Yeah, it doesn't
Lucia: 天呐谐音梗扣分哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my god, a pun, minus points, hahaha
Lucia: 没有反应过来
Lucia: I didn't get it at first
Lucia: 这个我们要放冰箱或者怎么样吗
Lucia: Do we need to put this in the fridge or what?
Lucia: 还是就在外面放着就行
Lucia: Or just leave it out?
Lucia: 如果一会就用来picknick了
Lucia: Since we're gonna use it for the picnic soon
Shure:  先不用放冰箱了
Shure: No need to put it in the fridge now
Alice: 不用放了下午不就拿走了
Alice: No need, we'll take it this afternoon
Shure:  阴凉遮光无光处对
Shure: Just keep it in a cool, shaded place
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 嗯好再打一下我们又可以吃了
Lucia: Alright, let's hit it again and we can eat
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice: 这个是多出来的
Alice: This is extra
Alice: 要搁那吗
Alice: Should we put it there?
Shure:  是的哈哈哈
Shure: Yes, hahaha
Jake: 子豪我们再看一下充电宝吧
Jake: Zihau, let's check the power bank again
Jake: 对你你查
Jake: Yes, you check
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Check again
Shure:  这是重要素材
Shure: This is important material
Shure:  所以不可丢不可遗失
Shure: So it can't be lost
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Alice: 你们有空调遥控器在房间里吗
Alice: Do you have the air conditioner remote in your room?
Alice: Lucy
Alice: Lucia
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah?
Alice: 你的那个空调遥控器是在你房间吗
Alice: Is the air conditioner remote in your room?
Lucia: 啊我没注意
Lucia: Ah, I didn't notice
Lucia: 因为一直没在
Lucia: Because I wasn't in there
Lucia: 在这个外面
Lucia: It was outside
Alice: 你的呢
Alice: What about yours?
Shure:  我的不知道
Shure: I don't know about mine
Shure:  我的还开着呢
Shure: Mine is still on
Lucia: 你不冷吗
Lucia: Aren't you cold?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure:  他不
Shure: No
Shure:  他是完全自动
Shure: It's fully automatic
Shure:  就是冷了
Shure: It's just cold
Shure:  他会给我吹热风然后温度合适
Shure: He'll blow hot air for me and then the temperature is right
Shure:  他不吹风
Shure: He stops blowing
Alice: 我觉得你像个面团子
Alice: I think you look like a dough ball
Lucia: interesting
Lucia: Interesting
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why
Alice: 水多加面
Alice: Add more water to the dough
Alice: 面多加水
Alice: Add more dough to the water
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  昨天和麻酱也是
Shure: Yesterday with sesame paste too
Shure:  水多加面
Shure: Add more water to the dough
Shure:  水多加麻酱
Shure: Add more water to the sesame paste
Shure:  麻酱多加水
Shure: Add more sesame paste to the water
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 怪不得结局过去那么大一碗啊
Lucia: No wonder it turned out to be such a big bowl
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No no
Shure:  肯定都和上
Shure: I'm sure it mixed well
Lucia: 我的东西在京东上找不到怎么办呢
Lucia: What if I can't find my stuff on JD.com
Lucia: 淘宝
Lucia: Taobao
Alice: 我都是淘宝
Alice: I always use Taobao
Lucia: 我怕淘宝他到不了
Lucia: I'm afraid Taobao won't deliver to me
Alice: 到不了我就退了
Alice: If it can't deliver, I'll just return it
Lucia: 哈哈有道理啊
Lucia: Haha, that makes sense
Alice: 我一般就是他那种呃
Alice: I usually buy those that
Alice: 48小时24小时之内发货的
Alice: Ship within 48 or 24 hours
Alice: 我就买了
Alice: I just buy it
Alice: 买不到到不了就退了
Alice: If it can't be delivered, I return it
Lucia: 要不因为我在淘宝上看到了
Lucia: Or because I saw it on Taobao
Lucia: 我的那些渔网什么的
Lucia: Those fishing nets and stuff
Lucia: 我觉得还挺合适的
Lucia: I think it's quite suitable
Lucia: 那我还是淘宝上买算了
Lucia: So I'll just buy it on Taobao
Alice: 呃
Alice: Uh
Lucia: 这是用来装饰房间的
Lucia: It's for decorating my room
Shure:  渔网
Shure: Fishing net
Katrina:  捕梦网是不是
Katrina: Dreamcatcher, right?
Lucia: 哦没有就是
Lucia: Oh no, it's just
Lucia: 是对但是跟海有关
Lucia: Yes, but related to the sea
Lucia: 就我想的是
Lucia: What I was thinking is
Lucia: 可能做成地中海风格的那种
Lucia: Maybe make it Mediterranean style
Lucia: 蓝白的颜色
Lucia: Blue and white colors
Lucia: 但我发现我现在买的材料都是白的
Lucia: But I realized all the materials I bought are white.
Lucia: 还没有蓝材料呢
Lucia: I don't have any blue materials yet.
Alice: 如果你想做地中海风格
Alice: If you want to go for a Mediterranean style,
Alice: 我可以把高中的老师捐给你
Alice: I can donate my high school teacher to you.
Lucia: 把高中老师捐给我
Lucia: Donate your high school teacher to me?
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
Alice: 因为他是个地中海啊
Alice: Because he's a Mediterranean guy.
Lucia: 啊OK好
Lucia: Ah, okay, got it.
Jake: 那我再说
Jake: Let me ask again,
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have power?
Alice: 露西呀你还有电吗
Alice: Lucia, do you still have power?
Lucia: 嗯你在问我吗
Lucia: Hmm, are you asking me?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Tasha: 这个在录着呢
Tasha: This is still recording.
Jake: 你你你插掉
Jake: You, you, you unplug it.
Tasha: 直接插掉就行吗
Tasha: Just unplug it directly?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 还有60%
Tasha: It's still at 60%.
Jake: 嗯行可以
Jake: Hmm, okay, that's fine.
Shure:  你看那个磁吸压到头发了
Shure: Look, that magnet is pulling on the hair.
Lucia: 我打算把那个串珠还是买一串
Lucia: I plan to buy another string of beads.
Lucia: 好吧如果他来得及到
Lucia: Okay, if it arrives on time,
Lucia: 咱可能还能做一下那个水母灯
Lucia: maybe we can still make that jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 再来点欧根纱
Lucia: And add some organza.
Alice: 我本来昨天想买的
Alice: I was planning to buy it yesterday,
Alice: 然后发现跟我的啊
Alice: but then I realized it didn't match my...
Lucia: 啊我打算买一米的蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Ah, I plan to buy a meter of blue organza.
Lucia: 我可以在房间里面弄一下
Lucia: I can use it in the room,
Lucia: 然后剩下的就你如如果就算真的要做灯
Lucia: and the rest, if we really want to make the lamp,
Lucia: 它里面用的纱也很少
Lucia: it doesn't use much fabric inside.
Lucia: 就我们每个人可以弄一块
Lucia: We can each use a piece,
Lucia: 然后放在里面
Lucia: and put it inside.
Alice: 然后给他剪掉
Alice: Then cut it off.
Lucia: 对对就比较好看一些
Lucia: Yes, yes, it looks better that way.
Alice: 边角料可以旋转一下固定一下
Alice: The scraps can be twisted and fixed,
Alice: 然后贴贴
Alice: then pasted...
Alice: 贴在什么地方
Alice: Pasted somewhere.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Exactly.
Lucia: 我觉得你昨天安利给我的那个桌布
Lucia: I think the tablecloth you recommended yesterday
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: is really beautiful.
Alice: 嗯我也我也买桌布了
Alice: Hmm, I also bought a tablecloth.
Jake: 桌布桌布挂墙上
Jake: Tablecloth, tablecloth, hang it on the wall.
Lucia: 不是啦
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 桌布当然是放在桌子上
Lucia: The tablecloth is obviously for the table.
Jake: 你们有桌子吗
Jake: Do you guys have a table?
Alice: 我有一个小的
Alice: I have a small one.
Lucia: 他有小桌子
Lucia: He has a small table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 四十乘
Alice: Forty by...
Lucia: 我打算配一个塑料的小方桌
Lucia: I'm planning to get a small plastic square table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就会能轻一点
Lucia: It'll be lighter.
Lucia: 也不是很贵
Lucia: And not too expensive.
Lucia: 因为我那个架子实在是太丑了
Lucia: Because my current stand is really ugly.
Jake: 明白
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 无法改造我觉得
Lucia: I think it's impossible to fix.
Alice: 我觉得我们这个户型还挺好的
Alice: I think our layout is pretty good.
Alice: 因为比较小就
Alice: Because it's relatively small.
Shure:  往下东西
Shure: Keep it down.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Alice: 哎东西呢
Alice: Hey, where's the stuff?
Jake: 我们也整点喝的吧
Jake: Let's get something to drink.
Jake: 哈哈给给您倒点咖咖啡给您倒点水
Jake: Haha, let me pour you some coffee, or some water.
Shure:  谢谢
Shure: Thanks.
Katrina:  这咖啡吗
Katrina: Is this coffee?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  这好像昨天晚上调的
Katrina: This seems like it was made last night.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: Yeah, that's the one.
Jake: 这些应该都用过
Jake: These have probably all been used.
Jake: 来吧我们
Jake: Alright, let's...
Jake: 我们最后一名做到
Jake: Our last person will do it.
Katrina:  我怎么做到老板
Katrina: How should I do it, boss?
Alice: 最后一名
Alice: Last person.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我也不做
Jake: I'm not doing it either.
Jake: 就是呃我们最后一名开始
Jake: So, uh, our last person will start.
Jake: 呃介绍自己的礼物然后第一名
Jake: Uh, introduce their gift and then the first person...
Jake: 呃大家秀一轮之后然后第一名开始挑
Jake: Uh, after everyone shows off, the first place gets to pick.
Jake: 对对对我们排名了
Jake: Yes, yes, we've ranked.
Jake: 我们有电量96的
Jake: We have 96% battery.
Alice: 到1-2
Alice: To 1-2.
Alice: 嗯我在你后边
Alice: Hmm, I'm behind you.
Tasha: 呃我不知道
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha: 写了一个东西
Tasha: Wrote something.
Tasha: 乱七八糟的东西
Tasha: A bunch of random stuff.
Jake: 笑口常开
Jake: Keep smiling.
Tasha: 明信片
Tasha: A postcard.
Shure:  天下粮仓
Shure: Grain warehouse.
Tasha: 种植套餐
Tasha: A planting package.
Katrina:  呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This.
Tasha: 营养塔
Tasha: A nutrition tower.
Tasha: 营养土盆栽和培养米种这张卡片的
Tasha: Nutrient soil potted plants and cultivated rice seeds, this card.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  这鼓好用吗
Shure: Is this drum any good?
Katrina:  把这摆着
Katrina: Put this here.
Jake: 不要太玩
Jake: Don't play too much.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Lucia: 你说这个鼓吗
Lucia: You mean this drum?
Shure:  不是  蛊  虫子下蛊了
Shure: No, it's a curse, bug curse.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Shure:  这个怎么翻译成英文
Shure: How do you translate this into English?
Katrina:  100人就开始算塔罗了
Katrina: When there are 100 people, we start counting tarot.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 营养土啊
Tasha: Nutrient soil.
Lucia: 是椰土那种吗
Lucia: Is it coconut soil?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 香菇是长
Jake: Mushrooms grow.
Jake: 香菇是好
Jake: Mushrooms are good.
Tasha: 可以养狼蛛用
Tasha: You can use it to raise tarantulas.
Lucia: sorry狼蛛
Lucia: Sorry, tarantulas?
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对就是养狼蛛是要垫椰土的
Lucia: Yes, you need coconut soil to raise tarantulas.
Alice: 你有这爱好
Alice: You have this hobby?
Lucia: 我现在没养
Lucia: I don't raise them now.
Lucia: 我以前养过
Lucia: I used to raise them.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But
Jake: 你多大呀
Jake: How old are you?
Lucia: 被我养死了哈哈哈
Lucia: I accidentally let them die, haha.
Lucia: 呃4只宠物
Lucia: Uh, four pets.
Lucia: 那个岂不是狼蛛不舍他们偷吃养的
Lucia: Isn't that tarantula reluctant to let them steal the food?
Jake: 啊倒第二
Jake: Ah, second to last.
Jake: 倒数第二名
Jake: Second to last place.
Jake: 第二名吧
Jake: Second place.
Jake: 第二名
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 准备了一个手链
Alice: I prepared a bracelet.
Alice: 是帝王沙跟绿松石的哦
Alice: It's made of imperial sand and turquoise.
Alice: 朱砂 就是古代皇帝批折子用的那个红色的那个颜料就是从这边提取的
Alice: Cinnabar, the red pigment that ancient emperors used for their seals, is extracted from here.
Alice: 然后绿松石就是蓝绿色
Alice: And turquoise is bluish-green.
Alice: 因为有铜跟铁的那些
Alice: Because it contains copper and iron.
Alice: 哎不是铜
Alice: Oh, not copper.
Jake: 啥
Jake: What?
Alice: 铜跟
Alice: Copper and...
Shure:  朱砂
Shure: Cinnabar.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 铜跟豆铜跟铁
Alice: Copper and iron.
Alice: 然后他这个会呈现不同的颜色
Alice: So it can show different colors.
Alice: 主要是我觉得朱砂比较辟邪
Alice: Mainly, I think cinnabar wards off evil.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 是这样
Alice: That's it.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 谁电量多来着啊
Jake: Who had the most battery again?
Shure:  啊我我我最老
Shure: Ah, me, me, I'm the oldest.
Jake: 你多少来着
Jake: How much did you have again?
Shure:  我是十几
Shure: I had over ten.
Shure:  好像
Shure: I think.
Jake: 挺好哎
Jake: Pretty good, huh?
Jake: 你这啥玩意
Jake: What's that?
Shure:  这个是一个乐器
Shure: This is a musical instrument.
Shure:  它是一个叫做沙球的乐器
Shure: It's called a shaker.
Tasha: 原来这个放到这一直就是你的呀
Tasha: So this has always been yours?
Katrina:  哈哈哈已经被玩过了
Katrina: Haha, it's already been played with.
Shure:  已经被大家玩坏了
Shure: It's already been worn out by everyone.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure:  然后他可以这个样子
Shure: And you can use it like this.
Tasha: 然后呢
Tasha: And then?
Shure:  这是他的沙球作用
Shure: This is the effect of his sand balls.
Shure:  然后他还可以
Shure: And he can also...
Shure:  就是比如说
Shure: Like, for example...
Shure:  就是它会发出一些碰撞的声音
Shure: It can make some collision sounds.
Shure:  对然后
Shure: Yeah, and then...
Tasha: AMSR啊哈哈
Tasha: AMSR, haha.
Shure:  最最最酷炫的就是它可以摆起来
Shure: The coolest thing is that it can be set up.
Tasha: 好酷哈哈
Tasha: So cool, haha.
Shure:  然后配合摆动
Shure: And then combined with the movements...
Shure:  再加上一些
Shure: Add some...
Katrina:  摇滚的东西
Katrina: Rock elements.
Shure:  一些一点点魔法
Shure: A little bit of magic...
Shure:  然后就可以打出不一样的节奏型
Shure: And you can create different rhythms.
Shure:  就比如说像这个样子
Shure: Like this, for example.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 来一段
Jake: Play a section.
Shure:  这是来一段
Shure: Play a section.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 我以为你叫什么大大节了
Jake: I thought you were going to play some big rhythm.
Lucia: 不应该来点这个才艺表演吗
Lucia: Shouldn't we have a bit of a talent show?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  竹板这么一打呀
Shure: With the bamboo clappers in hand,
Shure:  别的咱不夸
Shure: We won't praise just anything.
Shure:  咱就夸夸咱那个狗不理包子
Shure: Let's praise our special Goubuli buns.
Shure:  哈哈这一种赛博快板吧
Shure: Haha, this is a kind of cyber clapper talk.
Shure:  可能非洲人的快板就是长这个样子
Shure: Maybe African clapper talk looks like this.
Shure:  哈哈哈这确实好像是一种非洲的乐器
Shure: Hahaha, this indeed seems like an African instrument.
Jake: OK
Shure:  他的学名我忘了叫啥了
Shure: I forgot its scientific name.
Shure:  反正大家都叫它砂锤啊砂球
Shure: Anyway, everyone calls it a shaker or sand ball.
Shure:  然后这是一个静音的
Shure: And this one is a silent one.
Shure:  就是它就是这种橡木的
Shure: It's made of oak.
Shure:  然后正常可能会有那种金属的
Shure: Normally, it might be made of metal.
Shure:  或者塑料的
Shure: Or plastic.
Shure:  就是音色是不一样的
Shure: So the sound is different.
Shure:  这个就比较不那么吵
Shure: This one's not that noisy.
Shure:  然后声音也稍微暖一些
Shure: And the sound is a bit warmer.
Shure:  然后送出一个留一个
Shure: I'll give one away and keep one.
Shure:  因为演出还需要用的
Shure: Because we still need it for the performance.
Shure:  哈哈哈不能把吃饭家伙事丢了
Shure: Hahaha, we can't throw away our meal ticket.
Jake: 你是什么演出要用
Jake: What performance are you using it for?
Shure:  就一些现场的演出也会用到的
Shure: Just some live performances.
Jake: 哈哈就煮饭啊
Jake: Haha, cooking?
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  制造一种氛围音的时候
Shure: When creating an ambient sound.
Lucia: 好像ASMR啊
Lucia: Like ASMR?
Shure:  我再配合这手链给你
Shure: I'll match it with this bracelet for you.
Katrina:  睡了
Katrina: Asleep.
Tasha: 睡了
Tasha: Asleep.
Lucia: 困了困了
Lucia: Feeling sleepy.
Alice: 摇酒天赋
Alice: Shaking drinks talent.
Shure:  嗯好哈哈哈好
Shure: Hmm, okay, hahaha, okay.
Katrina:  然后介绍我的吧
Katrina: Then introduce mine.
Katrina:  我就是前前前一段时间去成都玩
Katrina: A while back, I went to Chengdu.
Katrina:  然后去那个玉林路那一些古着店
Katrina: And visited some vintage shops on Yulin Road.
Katrina:  淘的一些
Katrina: Picked up some stuff.
Katrina:  呃就是钥匙扣和胸针
Katrina: Uh, like keychains and brooches.
Shure:  就是淘宝店淘的新东西是吗
Shure: So you got some new stuff from Taobao stores?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  对淘就是他他那个开店那个店主
Katrina: Yeah, the shop owner designs them themselves.
Katrina:  他们是自己设计的
Katrina: They have their own design studio.
Katrina:  就是自己是一个设计工作室
Katrina: And you can only buy them there.
Katrina:  然后就只有在他
Katrina: So I bought.
Katrina:  们那里能买到
Katrina: This giant panda.
Katrina:  然后买的是大熊猫的大熊猫
Katrina: This is a keychain.
Katrina:  这是钥匙扣
Katrina: And this is a brooch.
Katrina:  这是一个胸针
Katrina: It's a bird and a cat.
Katrina:  就是一个鸟和一个猫
Katrina: I don't know what it means.
Katrina:  我也不知道什么意思
Katrina: I just thought it was cute.
Katrina:  我只是觉得很可爱
Katrina: So I bought them to give to everyone.
Katrina:  我就买回来送给大家
Katrina: Okay, done.
Katrina:  好OK
Katrina: All right, okay.
Alice: Lucy
Alice: Lucy.
Jake: 好96
Jake: Okay, 96.
Katrina:  嗯抽口的话对这里面有一个marry me
Katrina: Hmm, there's one that says "marry me."
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 不是marry me
Lucia: Not "marry me."
Lucia: 就是我本来是就是有一个小手做的耳钉
Lucia: So, I originally had these small handmade earrings.
Lucia: 然后对这个其实很简单
Lucia: And actually, it's pretty simple.
Lucia: 就只要买打了孔的珠子
Lucia: You just need to buy some beads with holes.
Lucia: 和这个这个耳针
Lucia: And these earring posts.
Lucia: 然后拿热熔胶把它粘在一起就可以
Lucia: Then, use hot glue to stick them together.
Lucia: 对然后但是就是我我自己做完之后
Lucia: Yeah, but after I finished making them,
Lucia: 我觉得这个还那个效果还挺好
Lucia: I thought they turned out really well.
Lucia: 所以我做了好几对
Lucia: So, I made several pairs.
Lucia: 然后刚好就是这边要给大家
Lucia: And it just so happened that I needed to
Lucia: 就是给大家准备礼物
Lucia: prepare gifts for everyone.
Lucia: 我就准备了一个
Lucia: So, I made one.
Lucia: 感觉是自己的手做的话会比较有意义
Lucia: I felt a handmade gift would be more meaningful.
Lucia: 但是为什么我又去买了一个抽屉呢
Lucia: But why did I buy a drawer?
Lucia: 因为我发现这个盒子有点大
Lucia: Because I realized the box was a bit too big.
Lucia: 当我把它放到这盒子里面的时候
Lucia: When I put them inside the box,
Lucia: 他们俩显得非常的孤单
Lucia: they looked really lonely.
Lucia: 然后我为了增加开盒的时候的气势
Lucia: So, to make the unboxing more impressive,
Lucia: 我就又去买了一个抽壳放在里面
Lucia: I bought an extra drawer to put inside.
Lucia: 然后但这样一放
Lucia: And when I placed it,
Lucia: 就会完全挡住他们两个
Lucia: It will completely block the two of them.
Lucia: 所以就是对
Lucia: So, yeah.
Lucia: 于是这个礼物
Lucia: So this gift
Lucia: 就变成了一个复合装饰的样子
Lucia: turned into a composite decoration.
Lucia: 然后这个就很就是这个
Lucia: And this, well, this
Lucia: 我觉得还蛮好看的
Lucia: I think it looks pretty good.
Lucia: 因为它是那种丝绒的料
Lucia: Because it's made of velvet material.
Lucia: 就是穿很多裙子都可以搭配
Lucia: It can match with many dresses.
Lucia: 但是男孩子的话就不考虑了
Lucia: But for boys, it's not really an option.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  行了
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure:  你怎么能定定义我
Shure: How could you define me like that?
Lucia: 对不起对不起我错了啊
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, I was wrong.
Shure:  我就是你看正好两个嘛
Shure: It's just that you see, it's perfect for two, right?
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia: 没有想到这一次
Lucia: Didn't expect this time
Lucia: 那那那说明你也是可以试用的
Lucia: that means you can also try it out.
Lucia: 那大家挑选起来就没有顾虑
Lucia: So everyone can choose without any worries.
Alice: 对呵
Alice: Yeah, right.
Shure:  好话都
Shure: Okay, you said all the nice things.
Shure:  让你说完了
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright
Jake: 那路亚开始
Jake: Then, let's start with the lure.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Jake: 这怎么挑的
Jake: How do we pick this?
Lucia: 我以为是盲挑来着
Lucia: I thought we were picking blind.
Jake: 咱盲挑
Jake: Let's pick blind.
Lucia: 感觉都很有特色的样子
Lucia: They all seem quite unique.
Shure:  先说一句好话
Shure: Say something nice first.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  憋出来了
Katrina: Squeezed it out.
Jake: 那咱要不盲挑也可以要不
Jake: So, we can either pick blind or...
Lucia: 我我我摇个骰子吧
Lucia: I'll roll a dice.
Lucia: 那就要不
Lucia: How about that?
Shure:  行
Shure: Sure.
Lucia: 嗯可以抽到我自己怎么办
Lucia: Hmm, what if I draw myself?
Katrina:  一二
Katrina: One, two...
Alice: 再来一轮
Alice: Let's go another round.
Katrina:  4
Katrina: Four.
Shure:  1234 对咱们
Shure: 1234, right, we...
Lucia: 对咱们
Lucia: Yes, we...
Lucia: 咱们的群呢
Lucia: Our group...
Lucia: 我放到我就在咱们群里摇好了
Lucia: I'll roll it in our group chat.
Shure:  公平公正公开
Shure: Fair, just, and open.
Shure:  sorry
Shure: Sorry.
Katrina:  特别可爱是不是
Katrina: Isn't it super cute?
Jake: 直播摇骰子
Jake: Live dice rolling.
Lucia: 2 我结果大家能看得到吗
Lucia: Two. Can everyone see the result?
Lucia: 发了一个
Lucia: Sent one.
Tasha: 看到了
Tasha: Saw it.
Alice: 二
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 二
Lucia: Two.
Alice: 谁是2
Alice: Who is two?
Lucia: 按介绍说明
Lucia: According to the instructions...
Alice: 我是2
Alice: I'm two.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 谢谢可馨
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Lucia: 啊这个包装也好好看
Lucia: Ah, this packaging is so nice.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 色子是在表情里吗
Lucia: Are the dice in the emojis?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Katrina:  表情里
Katrina: In the emojis
Jake: 那我们第二
Jake: Then our second...
Jake: 第二名来挑
Jake: The second place picks
Jake: 倒数第二名来挑
Jake: The second last place picks
Shure:  哈哈你挑的你都都不那什么了
Shure: Haha, the one you picked, you didn't even...
Shure:  客套话都不说直接闪了
Shure: You didn't even say anything polite, just left
Katrina:  我
Katrina: I...
Katrina:  哈哈迫不及待啊
Katrina: Haha, can't wait
Katrina:  会直接搜色子
Jake: 这是真色子 假色子每次都能摇6
Jake: These are real dice, fake dice always roll 6
Shure:  哎你这是固定三的
Shure: Hey, yours is fixed at 3
Katrina:  真假
Katrina: Really?
Katrina:  什么叫固定3
Katrina: What do you mean by fixed at 3?
Jake: 那再再忍一下你自己
Jake: Then hold on, you...
Shure:  一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey
Shure:  不是3是我  3是我
Shure: If it's not 3, it's me. 3 is me
Jake: 等一下我再再再摇一下看是固定的吗
Jake: Wait a sec, let me roll again and see if it's fixed
Alice: 不是吧不是
Alice: No way, it's not
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, it's not
Jake: OK那那行那行
Jake: OK, then it's fine
Katrina:  还是3
Katrina: Still a 3
Lucia: 还是3
Lucia: Still a 3
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Eh
Shure:  你没有表这个表情吗
Shure: Don't you have that expression?
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh
Jake: 咬出一个亿
Jake: Roll a billion
Lucia: 哦咬出一个亿
Lucia: Oh, roll a billion
Katrina:  给我自己
Katrina: For myself
Shure:  那就3吧
Shure: Then let's go with 3
Jake: 就三三好
Jake: Just 3, 3 is good
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh
Katrina:  哈哈哈每天晚上你会听到我在房间
Katrina: Hahaha, you'll hear me in my room every night
Shure:  没事我在你楼下
Shure: It's fine, I'm downstairs
Jake: 好那到你摇吧
Jake: Alright, your turn to roll
Jake: 你倒啊
Jake: You go
Shure:  我我摇吧还是
Shure: Should I roll or...
Jake: 你客套话呢
Jake: Your polite words?
Shure:  客套话就是
Shure: Polite words are just
Katrina:  谢谢大家
Katrina: Thank you, everyone.
Shure:  大家每个都非常的棒
Shure: Everyone did a great job.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then
Shure:  让我实在难以割舍
Shure: It's really hard for me to choose.
Shure:  选哪个割舍其他的
Shure: Choosing one means giving up the others.
Shure:  都是一种
Shure: It's all a kind of
Katrina:  演上了
Katrina: Here comes the performance.
Shure:  我是几 四
Shure: Am I number four?
Shure:  1234 呀
Shure: 1234, right?
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  这么可爱的送给你
Katrina: Such a cute one for you.
Shure:  哪有
Shure: No way.
Katrina:  送给你哈哈送给你
Katrina: For you, haha, for you.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 达成了交换
Lucia: The exchange is done.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Nice.
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we
Shure:  剩下二位就变成交换了
Shure: The remaining two will be exchanging.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 你得给我
Alice: You need to give it to me.
Alice: 然后他再给你
Alice: Then he'll give it to you.
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Shure:  完了
Shure: Done.
Shure:  没抽到洋鼓很可惜
Shure: It's a pity we didn't draw the drum.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那就收拾收拾准备出发
Jake: Let's pack up and get ready to go.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  你这个要导数据吗
Katrina: Do you need to import this data?
Jake: 要
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  你之前要倒一会啊
Katrina: You need to import it first.
Tasha: 这钱我也不知道怎么啊
Tasha: I don't know what to do with this money.
Tasha: 就是好看
Tasha: It's just so pretty.
Shure:  卡掉
Shure: Cut it off.
Jake: 呃先先带回带回去
Jake: Uh, first, take it back.
Jake: 然后带到一楼
Jake: Then bring it to the first floor.
Jake: 放到那个
Jake: Put it there.
Tasha: 你可以把它
Tasha: You can put it...
Jake: 盒里边
Jake: Inside the box
Tasha: 那个是书法课上面老师
Tasha: That was from the calligraphy class teacher
Tasha: 呃统一买的
Tasha: Uh, it was bought together
Lucia: 哦可以好奇一下写的什么
Lucia: Oh, can I be curious about what's written?
Alice: 笑口常开
Alice: Always smiling
Lucia: 哇好好看啊
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good
Lucia: 写的好好
Lucia: Written so well
Alice: 回眸
Alice: Glancing back
Jake: 啊谁写的
Jake: Ah, who wrote this?
Jake: 你写的哦
Jake: You wrote this?
Lucia: 微微写的
Lucia: Tasha wrote it
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: It looks so good
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive
Shure:  是不是有点太短了
Shure: Isn't it a bit too short?
Alice: 也差不多
Alice: It's about right
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 就大家把礼物放到自己房间
Jake: Everyone put their gifts in their own rooms
Jake: 然后下去再一起结束就结束了
Jake: Then we'll go downstairs and wrap things up together
Katrina:  放到自己的房间
Katrina: Put it in your own room
Alice: 是上一年
Alice: It was last year
Alice: 去年冬天写的
Alice: Written last winter
Tasha: 对哎我
Tasha: Yes, I
Jake: 我跳舞了
Jake: I danced
Alice: 今年是甲醛
Alice: This year it's formaldehyde
Jake: 在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: Dancing outside, glancing back
Shure:  回眸
Shure: Glancing back
Jake: 你们得在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: You guys need to dance outside and glance back
Jake: 然后拍拍照
Jake: Then take pictures
Jake: 拍完照最后一天放PPT
Jake: After taking pictures, show the PPT on the last day
Alice: 我念对念惯了
Alice: I'm used to reciting it
Shure:  这样呢应该是
Shure: This way, it should be
Jake: 对就是pick lick是跳舞对吧
Jake: Yes, pick lick is dancing, right?
Jake: 准备好防晒准备好
Jake: Get ready with sunscreen, get ready
Shure:  玩吧
Shure: Let's play
Jake: 呃拍拍照准备最后一天放PPT准备好
Jake: Uh, take pictures and get ready to show the PPT on the last day
Jake: 对就是手机拍拍照
Jake: Yes, take pictures with your phone
Lucia: 为什么我会砸到我自己的手
Lucia: Why did I hit my own hand?
Shure:  因为它长
Shure: Because it's long
Shure:  哦不不不就是夹的
Shure: Oh no no no, it's just clamped.
Jake: 呃对OK
Jake: Uh, yeah, OK.
Jake: 然后准备买肉
Jake: Then get ready to buy meat.
Lucia: 不行我还是会砸到自己的手
Lucia: No way, I'll still hit my own hand.
Jake: 晚上还有烤串
Jake: There will be skewers tonight.
Jake: BBQ晚上烤串加甜点
Jake: BBQ tonight, skewers and dessert.
Tasha: 下午是要出去吗
Tasha: Are we going out this afternoon?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Okay?
Katrina:  晚上还有披萨
Katrina: There's also pizza tonight.
Katrina:  两个够了不用再点
Katrina: Two is enough, no need to order more.
Jake: 这下午茶是披萨
Jake: This afternoon's tea is pizza.
Jake: 可能在外边你们走累了吃俩披萨
Jake: Maybe you'll get tired walking outside, so have two pizzas.
Katrina:  哦你说让披萨带出去
Katrina: Oh, you mean to take the pizzas out?
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我得换件衣服
Katrina: I need to change clothes.
Katrina:  我得装这个东西没口袋
Katrina: I need to pack this stuff, no pockets.
Katrina:  装裤子
Katrina: Pack it in my pants.
Shure:  确实很治愈
Shure: It's really healing.
Shure:  来杨老板坐这
Shure: Come on, Jake, sit here.
Shure:  我给你治愈一下
Shure: I'll heal you a bit.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Ouch ouch.
Lucia: 给你听个现场的鲜花
Lucia: Let me play you some live flowers.
Jake: 环绕声是吧
Jake: Surround sound, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一般拿个颂锅先duang
Shure: Usually, just take a singing bowl and duang.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 还是双摄
Lucia: It's still dual camera.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 挺好水平挺高
Jake: Pretty good, high level.
Jake: 自带混响
Jake: Comes with reverb.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈这视频可以录吗
Lucia: Haha, can this video be recorded?
Lucia: 晚上睡觉的时候就用来助眠用
Lucia: Use it to help sleep at night.
Jake: 可以你这卖钱吗
Jake: Sure, are you selling it?
Jake: 你要不你录一段
Jake: Why don't you record a segment?
Jake: 卖钱
Jake: And sell it.
Lucia: 你开一个
Lucia: You start one.
Jake: 卖多少钱
Jake: How much is this selling for?
Lucia: AMSR频道
Lucia: AMSR channel
Jake: 这个卖多少钱
Jake: How much is this selling for?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake: 你这个掉了
Jake: You dropped this.
Shure:  我这个可以摘了
Shure: Can I take this off?
Shure:  应该
Shure: Should be.
Jake: 行啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  是要导数据的是吧
Shure: We need to export the data, right?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice: 现在就导吗
Alice: Are we exporting it now?
Jake: 对他们把东西放回房间
Jake: Yes, they need to put things back in the room.
Jake: 然后把眼镜给解决
Jake: And then fix the glasses.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: And then we'll finish.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 放回去
Jake: Put it back.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: And then we'll finish.
Jake: 再都
Jake: And then...
Shure:  忘拿了
Shure: I forgot to take it.
Shure:  差点
Shure: Almost.
Jake: 不是放回去到下面一起结束这么回事
Jake: Not putting it back and finishing it all together?
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Okay, got it.
Shure:  最近还是一样努力着
Shure: Still working hard as usual.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 子堂开工
Jake: Starting work.
Katrina:  哎真好
Katrina: Oh, that's great.
Jake: 嗯开工
Jake: Yeah, starting work.
Jake: 对开工
Jake: Yes, starting work.
Shure:  然后我们
Shure: And then we...
Shure:  我们停掉
Shure: We stop it.
Katrina:  是我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Jake: 呃停OK
Jake: Uh, stop it, okay.
Jake: 行停掉
Jake: Alright, stop it.
Jake: 停掉停掉
Jake: Stop it, stop it.
Alice: 停掉了
Alice: It's stopped.
Jake: 停掉然后
Jake: Stop it, and then...